and here magnus carlsen comes
on sneamon in a very nice flowery shirt
and magnus will make the first move we
know hans neyman has a chessball course
coming out the job of london should
magnus then not play that opening yeah
magnus has not played d4 which might
lead towards the draba london system
instead we see a king's pawn opening
from the world champion and it's the
spanish
so uh hans nieman just reacting very
solidly with black one e45 locking
things up white is the first to cast for
the king but play will start to revolve
around the center of the board hans
niemann okay he takes a deep breath what
is he going to do here usually we see
black develop the dark squared bishop
out there's a couple of squares you
could choose black could push a pawn
black can even capture white pawn in the
center of the board with a black knight
and he does that one of the most
ambitious options we call this the open
spanish because things tend to open up
very quickly
so black temporarily is a pawn up but if
you look at black's king it's in the
middle it needs to get castled so black
is happy to give back a pawn in order to
catch up with peace development this is
still very well known stuff so far i
have a i have a question actually
because we always talk about taking
center and that black knight is that
taking centers as it's in the center or
is it not taking center because it's
basically not
aiming at any of the squares in the
center that's a good question actually
i've never thought of it like that
yeah black's night here it's been very
ambitious it's grabbed a pawn and it is
actually supported by black central pawn
but then again it could be a target for
white's pieces so i think it comes with
pros and cons it could be what we call
an octo knight just controlling eight
squares really powerful piece all blacks
knight in the center of the board could
just get traded off i'm expecting to see
maybe magnus at some point over the next
move or two bring out his knight the
knight that's asleep on the left side
and challenge black's knight in the
center it's just too strong
so uh okay he's just pushed a pawn first
this is still very standard as well
and uh now hans neiman will develop his
dark squared bishop most likely yeah and
one of the things i have realized about
this particular line that hans niemann
has played is it's quite forcing i mean
there's a long series of moves in the
database
and it's just wondering
is he planning to out prepare magnus
i think quite possibly because uh
yesterday i did notice from hans
niemann's games that he was very very
well prepared in the opening
he convincingly beat
david anton in his specialty at the
jabra london but it wasn't just david
anton it was also ding lorena as well
yeah some really impressive opening
preparation from the teenager from
newman okay there he brought his bishop
out as predicted white's knight and
bishop wow okay white's not in bishop
we're ganging up against the black
knight and we've seen some really quick
moves now we've actually seen a huge
transition black has given up a knight
and bishop in exchange for white's rook
but black does have a pawn in exchange
and look at the white king right now
it's forced slightly out into the open
and with black's last move he's trying
to open up the black rook at the top of
the board on the same line as the white
king he's trying to open up to attack
magnus but we've seen this before this
is still well known and this is actually
kind of cutting-edge theory it's debated
at the top level in several games
recently magnus himself had it i think
uh from the white side um last season on
the tour so okay we saw white give up
another pawn kaya you mentioned taking
center look at those black pawns in the
center of the board right now they're
super strong backed up by black's pieces
but material is roughly level white has
a bishop and a knight black has a rook
and two pawns in return so rook and two
pawns worth seven
two pieces of bushmen a night worth
roughly six sometimes more so um yeah
it's really tense really complex and the
evaluation bar has been swinging left
and right because even studying with
computers it's unclear
who has the advantage i think in
practical terms it's very difficult to
play with white so magnus must have come
armed uh with preparation opening
preparation to this game exactly you'd
expect that right the black pieces look
very developed though yeah i looked at
this once and i was terrified i was just
too scared to play it with white because
if you look at white's pieces half of
them are asleep also the white king a
bit open a bit airy and black central
pawns just too strong but then again if
white's bishops come to life if the two
white bishops which are actually
pointing towards the king side if they
can start creating some threats if the
white knights can start hopping forward
it's nice to have minor pieces uh in
certain types of positions so magnus has
to try and just survive the next few
moves and then the white minor pieces
the knights and bishops might come to
life but it's scary and i think but
magnus is being brave going into this
hans is being very ambitious uh playing
such a kind of complex line against
someone's so strong as magnus yeah and i
do have to say up until um hans last
move stepping forward with the queen two
squares the players were actually
following the game that you referenced
that was magnus carlsen against uh
shakaria mahmoud from the tour finals
there magnus actually won
so
here i'm just taking a look taking a
look at my database and i can see that
the schools are
i would say
edging in black's paper okay so it's a
sharp sharp line
players who just recently played it
fabiano park fabiana caruana played this
against jordan van forest very recently
in the tata steel eric hanson
also played against the jordan van
forest there it wasn't very successful
for eric and also maxine bachelor graf
has also played it okay so some real
pedigree some real
giants of uh giants of chess playing
this opening and magnus now he's brought
his bishop out and to me that's slightly
mysterious it looks like white's bishop
is active but it's actually hitting thin
air it's not actually attacking any
pieces um it could provoke a pawn push
later
by one of black's pawns near the king
just to kick that bishop away but maybe
magnus is hoping hoping to loosen things
up around the black king ivanka has this
one been played before nope hasn't been
played before
but uh yes and no because it has been
analyzed someone has gone into the
database and had a check hey what
happens if white develops the bishop to
the g5 square and they've analyzed two
moves this was actually in june 2021
they analyzed directly attacking the
white knight sitting on f3 or a very
kind of calm sensible move which is also
just to tuck the king away into the
corner okay so two very sensible moves
as you mentioned tucking the king away
in the corner now the king is super safe
if you want to keep it even safer an
idea we actually mentioned yesterday on
our broadcast the bishop could always
drop back to actually keep the light
square safe around the black king so a
very nice defensive maneuver but we know
hans neiman we know he's not yeah i
don't think he wants to play safety
first chess he's not a defensive player
by nature he wants to be aggressive
ambitious he wants to attack
even players like magnus carson no fear
so a move we might well see is pawn to
e4 attacking this white knight and now
this white knight once it is dislodged
i'm expecting it to maybe land in the
center black can start to bring pieces
as well towards the white king for
example the black knight can move
forward trying to maybe cause an attack
later on uh black's pawns could start
what we call a pawn storm an avalanche
of pawns all of black's pawns rushing
forward this would be very very tense
and to be honest the more i look at this
the more i'm attracted to it for the
black side i think hans newman has a
chance to start going on the offensive
against the world champion and
he knows no fear and normally that type
of attitude will
give you results even against the best
players you can't just play quiet moves
even though this is very sensible it
just feels a bit too slow so uh okay
what will hans do will he play a quiet
move like tucking his king in the corner
or will he
start pushing horns forward creating
threats and forcing magnus onto the back
foot
yeah really really tense position i'm
loving these two pawns now for black i'm
loving this open file as well for the
rook and uh okay magnus will have to
really produce some defensive ideas and
he of course he goes for it the most
aggressive move there by hans niemann
pushing a pawn forward hitting this
white knight yeah and uh i was going to
ask you a question uh just based on my
observations of hans niemann so he's
incredibly confident and so this leads
me to believe that he's an optimist and
i was going to ask you are you an
optimist or a pessimist when it comes to
chats
that's a good question um actually i saw
a meme recently where okay the black
knight does indeed land in the center so
we're expecting this and now the pawn is
going to push forward kick the knight
but yeah i saw a meme on twitter
recently and it was just a picture of a
glass and obviously the question is is
the glass glass half full or half empty
and i think someone like hans niemann
would say the glass is full
so yeah it's uh i i think i've always
been a bit of a pessimist uh
i try and uh look for the pros and uh
and positives in my position but
i also like to take the safety first
option if uh if in doubt especially when
i'm low on time so
but the safety at first option is also
really good because it means you're
always considering what your opponent is
going to be thinking about
whereas
if you're just optimist
you do have to be careful that you don't
swing all the way to the other side and
just be reckless and not consider what
that your opponent to
has uh has a chance at playing the game
yeah you need to be objective that's the
main thing you have to have know roughly
the evaluation of the position so you
can take major decisions
um yeah you can't be too optimistic that
you forget everything but you can't be
too pessimistic where you just play for
the draw or play passively put your
piece on bad squares so okay meanwhile a
couple of moves white's other knight
jumping forward the white knight that
was sat next to the king and uh black's
bishop has just retreated one square
very solid there this last move by
nieman but he has this idea that we
mentioned of black sea pawn
coming down the board and hitting
white's knight in the center uh if that
had happened on the last turn white
tonight in the center could have
captured the black bishop and
after that trade i think that would have
favored magnus so okay still really
interesting stuff both players playing
quite quickly up to this point we're
already on move 19. both players have
over 13 minutes left
so yeah i mean i think both players have
started really really well today
already a cool game it is incredibly
incredibly exciting and uh
for me i'm just looking at the position
and i'm considering
david's idea you know attacking the
night with a pawn and suddenly those
three pawns in the middle of the board
look really really scary and uh the
question for white is should they take
some action against this you know is
that backwards with a knight or should
they just go well fine it's not a
problem
the
pessimist in me is thinking take action
don't allow it
yeah but then
the optimist and you what does the
optimist and you say anchor oh it
doesn't matter step forward with the
queen
exactly
uh the knight will retreat once it's
attacked and uh then the question
becomes of what is black going to be
doing um
i don't know which wolf is winning
actually the battle there uh i think
probably the
the cowardly wolf
i agree uh okay magnus isn't a coward
though and uh he goes for one of the
optimistic approaches he's actually just
ignoring black's pawn pushers so black
now could pick up that c pawn and push
it two squares forward hitting white's
knight in the center of the board but
the white knight will just retreat and
at the moment magnus has everything
under control the reason he's retreated
his bishop there uh to the edge of the
board is because he wants to kind of
zigzag his bishop back this like uh this
white dark square bishop that has moved
he wants to drop it back one square just
to kind of eye up the black queen the
black knight and black queen are on the
same diagonal so uh really sneaky move
there from magnus and yeah the
optimistic pessimistic thing i think
that affects me the most in positions
where you have an option to attack but
it involves some risk
when i was young i would just go for the
attack every time i was confident it
would work i wouldn't even calculate
sometimes i just trust myself uh but
these days the older i get the more i
believe in defense and that's maybe why
i'm pessimistic and i know hands for uh
for sure he is uh believing any time he
gets a chance yeah to throw pawns
forward throw pieces forward yeah it's
it's an intriguing question because i've
been kind of thinking a lot about this
issue um especially when it comes to
life's approaches whether you should be
looking with a gap mentality or a gain
mentality and they were saying you know
if you're an optimist it allows you to
be more creative in life and also in
chess and it enables you just to see
things out of the box
and i must admit magnus has been very
optimistic in his position he's like i
don't care i don't mind about black
attacking the knight and as a result of
that he's come up with a really
unconventional way of
maneuvering his bishop to a better
diagonal and suddenly white's position
has a lot of harmony whereas maybe you
wouldn't have thought about that if
you'd just been instinctively reacting
to black's
plans yeah true if you compared the
white knights
as they are now to how they were five
moves ago white snipes were previously
just passive not doing much this bishop
that we you just mentioned ivanka the
white dark squared bishop
it's looking great at the side of the
board actually um and it will look even
better next move
especially compared to how it was a few
moves ago so magnus is improving with
every turn and hans needs to do that
yeah
has magnus become more pessimistic with
age in his style as well um
i wouldn't say necessarily pessimistic
just maybe more practical
occasionally we see him take a quick
draw in the final round of tournaments
just to secure his place we saw in the
2016 world championship match he took a
draw against sergey karjakin in the last
game with white very quickly just to
ensure he got to the playoffs so i think
he's got his eye on the result more than
maybe beauty in each game these days
but i think that's natural uh in sport
players i mean athletes they tend to
retire maybe in their 30s because
physical things are taking over and it's
hard to keep battling and keep kind of
pushing yourself but i think in chess
the reason maybe we get slightly worse
with age is because we become less
creative
and
at least for me and at least a lot of
other chess players i know um we often
end up playing maybe passive chess solid
chess rather than going for all-out
attacks rather than playing aggressive
openings so so what is the prime age for
chess they say 35 yeah okay so magnus
actually isn't there yet yeah i would
say maybe slightly earlier but uh i
think you can you can go on for longer
at a high level but it's definitely hard
uh i mean i would love to be hanza's age
again
just attacking every turn and wow wow
okay hang on wow that's an amazing move
yeah and the reason we both reacted
there is because magnus has just given
up a knight the knight has just jumped
forward attacking the black queen but
this knight is attacked twice by black's
bishop and by black's rook and it's only
defended once we have to investigate
this it's either genius or it's gonna
backfire on the world champion on the
last turn if we rewind just to show what
hans did he actually created a double
attack hitting this bishop and hitting
the white knight with his queen and
magnus reacted by jumping forward so
this knight actually has many purposes
here it's attacking the black queen but
it's also defending the bishop as we
mentioned and defending its own knight
so you have to remove it
what else if you take this knight
magnus's idea is actually to maybe
recapture first and after the rook takes
white is a piece down but after queen
takes pawn this is a check and another
double attack so it's all about double
attacks right now it's all about
multi-purpose moves and here after black
blocks the check or runs out of the
check you would just lose the rook in
the corner this would actually end in a
back rank checkmate so magnus has some
serious threats and hans has he missed
this move maybe he's forgotten that the
queen is going to take this pawn and
it's going to be devastating
how is he going to deal with this i'm
shocked the evaluation part is on black
side
so far because i don't see how you react
i i also don't see how to react as well
and the more i look at it you know black
can't even just go oops i made a mistake
didn't see that move move my queen away
because you know if you do that then
there's going to be a night check at the
very least or you can even be flashy and
go queen takes porn yeah but uh but it's
better to be play safe and go night
check but it's the same idea after the
king moves now you can play queen takes
pawn uh this knight protected by white's
bishop on the side of the board we
mentioned white's minor pieces the
bishops and knights coming to life and
after a queen trade now if we just do a
quick count white has a bishop and a
knight and also very strong bishops and
knights
for the black rook
yes black has a pawn but this guy is
under attack uh this guy is under attack
in the middle of the board black has too
many weaknesses white's pieces are
better than the black rooks and this
just looks winning for white so
what now is in store here what could
hans be thinking about
let's go back to the players maybe
there's a sneaky night check maybe
there's some tactics but either way
magnus finding a we talked about
creativity
he still has some left he find uh he
found that a really creative move
and hans needs to deal with his problems
everything attacked
what a beautiful move from magnus uh
like i don't see him i don't see a
response i think uh
hans niemann just blundered yeah he was
careless and uh was too much in his own
head thinking about attacking and he's
just missed this
wonderful wonderful move because at
first sight you think well the night
come just go there and often you
often stronger players will actually
rule out this type of move
just because automatically you know
these are like no it's covered square's
covered don't need to do anything else
yeah and uh this is what's happened here
and uh incredible incredible by magnus
and i did see before magnus made that
move he was sitting in deep deep
thoughts with his head and his hands
while
actually hans was was making his move
seems to be something he's planning
yeah maybe magnus had kind of seen this
trick this kind of trap in advance and
he was kind of hoping hans would fall
into it but also magnus was just trying
to calculate ahead to
figure out that it does indeed work
because actually just thinking about it
now
magnus his previous move it relied on
this trick
if the black queen did swing across as
it did uh then white would have been in
big trouble if this night move wasn't
available and as ivanka mentioned i
think this is called an invisible move
in a way so it's putting a piece on a
square that looks like it's well covered
by the enemy pieces but often it's the
most effective because three or four
pieces might be covering the same square
but if you put something on that square
only one of your posts pieces can take
it and you often ruin their
the opponent's coordination so um yeah
right now what black's coordination is
just ruined white meanwhile just too
many threats and
what's happened to the evaluation by i'm
surprised because i'm like you ivanka i
don't see what black does so you you
would you know you would have placed it
to the other side yeah how far how far
on minus the side how big of an
advantage would you say this looks a
winning advantage so it would be over
plus one
okay so he captures the night okay
that's not going to change much because
well one night was on f5 another night
appears
and i'm thinking maybe hans can
try to
confuse things a little bit
yeah maybe throwing the night check i
mean maybe now it's too late so should
he now not take with the rook like you
showed us earlier if black takes with
the rook after the queen comes up the
board with that double attack white wins
immediately
so that knight is poisoned you cannot
capture it but what else
you have to move the black queen in that
case or as ivanka mentioned maybe throw
in the black knight
give a check to the white king just to
again ruin the coordination between your
opponent's pieces but i don't see that
working really okay he does that okay
but uh okay what is magnus going to do
is he going to be really sneaky and
captured with his queen
has captured with his queen so giving up
his queen
but the black queen would have been
captured if black had captured the white
queen so black instead flicking in a
check there's some crazy tactics now wow
yeah
i mean so many unexpected moves we just
have to show this um if we just rewind
two moves here black gave a check
hitting the white king with the knight
and rather than play the most obvious
move pawn takes knight which would have
allowed rook takes knight and naturally
now the central pawn is guarded so white
can't play queen takes pawn check this
was really sneaky by hands but instead
magnus in this position played queen
takes knight again a bit of an invisible
move not obvious but now if the queen is
captured knight takes queen is a check
black has to recapture and here we for
example after pawn takes bomb we compare
two bishops against one of the black
rooks the two bishops are simply better
two pieces are better than one in the
sit uh in this situation so instead
black gave a check now the queen is safe
hitting the white king but magnus how's
he reacted he's blocked with his queen
and uh after we see a trade of queens in
this position again we do account two
bishops against black's rook and
yeah the bishops are simply going to be
too powerful also look at black's pawn
structure it looks nice in the center
but these pawns are weak these doubled
pawns and also these pawns are actually
completely controlled by this white
bishop this bishop controls the whole
diagonal they can never march forward
white is simply going to bring the rook
to the center bring this bishop to
better diagonal and start targeting the
black pawns and maybe even the black
king later in the game i think this is
going to be quite one-sided now it feels
like the two bishops are just too
powerful they control everything yeah
and uh yeah we talk about minor pieces
and rooks but two bishops are nearly
always better than one rook yeah and i
have to just admire magnus's last move
because whilst i perhaps would have
centralized my rook immediately he takes
the time out as always to improve this
worst place piece he's like okay well
the bishop's not doing much let's
improve it with time by attacking the
pawn on b6 and then he can get on with
the plan of just attacking those pawns
located on the light squares
and uh yeah i do agree with you i think
it's almost game over for hans and e-man
yeah maybe we're being too pessimistic
here but uh i think we're just being
realistic actually in this situation if
black for example defends this pawn
that's under fire uh as you mentioned
ivanka then the rook just comes across
black is helpless
you just can't defend these two pawns in
the center uh once the bishop arrives on
this diagonal right all of black pawns
are going to drop like dominoes now yeah
i do remember a long long time ago um
my brother laughing at one of my games
and you know it was one of these
scenarios where it was a rook versus the
bishop at night and he was just like
going to me hey you do realize that two
pieces or you know work better than one
and i'm like okay yeah i've never really
thought about that but it is a case of
maths you know there's two attackers
here in this case the bishop and the
rook and also two bishops and they're
just going to be facing
a rook
so there's three of these guys now and
they're all going to gang up on pawns
and there's only two pieces today
exactly and just simple maths and
yeah a really sad sad situation for hans
niemann it's not really what he wanted
you know he was all gung-ho yesterday he
was
really you know gearing himself for a
hard-fought fight and especially because
he had mentioned in the air things
masters in their account encounter he
had been really ambitious and then this
had turned around in magnus's favor and
now here it's just
one way one way of traffic yeah and uh
just noticed that hans has probably the
best air quality we've seen throughout
the entire oh yeah there's lots of green
circles there but yeah unfortunately
it's not going to help him in the
position and it was just one move just
one move he underestimated magnus's
trick this night jump we mentioned that
knight and f5 will thrive the rhyme that
we came up with but sometimes one move
is all it takes and i expect white's
rook to actually come up to the center
of the board right now
there we go and there's actually a
threat the rook wants to capture the
pawn next to it because there's a pin on
black central pawn and
that black king is actually caught in
the crossfire
just no way to save your pawns now
blacks
horns in the center of the board are
doomed
and hands
he's trying he's trying to focus but
slight shake of the head there
and not much else to say the world
champion
we've seen a bit of shaky form from him
in the prelim stages in the past but
this is just a matter of technique and
he's also a phenomenal end game player
so he should be able to wrap this one up
and uh look at that liam another win for
him taking him to
13 points on top of the table winning
against gwayne jones ah
your fellow englishman is really
struggling in this tournament yeah i
mean
hopefully i mean it's not the end of the
tournament there's still lots and lots
of games left so you know we do wish
gawain or the best of luck
and uh there you go one pawn is going to
fall off the board
yeah
that's central porn definitely white can
maybe just take it right now knowing
magnus he might not rush he'd push some
pawns himself he can
i mean he's got all the time in the
world
he's a maximalist isn't he so now i
agree with you i'm going to push upon
attack there
he takes it yeah that is uh up for grabs
that pawn and also maybe a small detail
but an important one now black's rook
cannot come to attack this white bishop
in the center of the board which would
actually be very strong for black apart
from the fact white's bishop the dark
square bishop can actually come to the
side back where it came from earlier and
deliver a nasty check
so
brutal it's like everything has gone
wrong for hans you know it's like even
this queen trade where he get into this
ending it wasn't really great for him
because of the pawn structure and even
now you know his one chance of
generating counter play like you say
denied
reigns
yeah
and uh
whilst we're waiting for hans neiman to
make a decision
i do have a nice selfie to show you can
i quickly show it to you it's from ari
and uh
ari is watching football for the end for
the eyes and chess for the ears thank
you ari
what an evening lucky that the
commentary is so good but you can do
both
and there you can see yeah watching
actually watching it so much yeah wow i
know very simple so a big shout out to
ari and remember if you do want to tweet
us your questions your selfies and you
can use the hashtag chesschamps and can
we recognize that arena david
i know tottenham west ham currently
playing
uh what for ever no that's not being
played today harry you can hear us so
let us know
and uh okay meanwhile just a couple of
moves hands deciding his pawns are going
to drop anyway eventually he gave up one
of his double pawns in order to open a
line for the black rook so we've been a
bit uh negative about hans's chances of
saving this game we've been
predicting the future and thinking it's
going to be a white win but he's still
fighting he's still creating uh counter
play so this black rook on an open file
it actually threatens a deadly check if
black has a move to bring it down to the
bottom of the board and trap white's
king on the back rank but unfortunately
magnus spots that idea and going to grab
a porn he's created also meanwhile an
escape route for the white king and uh
suddenly white has an extra pawn earlier
black had a whole army of pawns but now
they're starting to fall and white's
king dancing away from the checks
even if the black goes and grabs one or
two pawns the bishops will pick up even
more pawns in the process i think
all that hans will grab his one pawn and
magnus won't allow him to grab anything
else yeah
bit sneaky from magnus carlsen uh if
black's rook actually comes up on the b
file and captures the pawn two squares
uh in front of it then black the white
dark square bishop sorry will drop back
with a check and a double attack you
have to keep your rook and king as far
away apart from each other otherwise the
bishops might
uh trap that rook so
yeah it's
taking like not much chance anymore
white bishop in the center of the board
also hitting a pawn on the other side
yeah i was going to mention that as well
you know just a really unlucky scenario
for hans newman you know makes one
mistake
and everything goes wrong and you know
all his pieces are in the most
unfortunate uh squares and
just no way out and uh yeah pieces as
well now yeah but in that moment uh so
hans nina i don't know if we should call
it a blunder and inaccuracy but how
impressed are you with magnus
finding that plan and magnus's play in
this game
i'm highly impressed to be honest i mean
he firstly he looks super focused which
hasn't always been the case in the
prelims but
secondly
even after he got that chance he's been
ruthless i mean he actually traded off
everything the queens the rooks um pawns
just to make it as safe as possible and
he's still got this advantage of two
bishops against one lone rook
so yeah magnus actually if we analyze
this he's probably played a perfect game
wow i don't think we can fault any of
his moves
and meanwhile hans has tried he's only
actually made one mistake hands but at
this top level
that's all it takes yeah unfortunately
there are different types of mistakes
you know you have your slight
inaccuracies well the game about
evaluation doesn't change that much you
have blunders
where you know you kind of your your
opponent has the
um initiative has the flow and then you
have like game changing blunders and
okay there you go you can see it has
neiman has resigned magnus carlsen has
won wow it's over um a win for magnus
carlsen to start off